>> Chris: IT'S 11:59 AND 59
SECONDS.
THIS HAPPENED ON YOUTUBE.
WHILE WE WERE ON BREAK JJ ABRAMS
SHOWED KIM KARDASHIAN'S BIG
GREASY BUTT WHAT IT'S REALLY
MEANT TO BREAK THE INTERNET
WHEN HE RELEASED A NEW TRAILER
FOR STAR WARS: THE FORCE
AWAKENS.
WHICH IS THIS.
>> HAVE YOU FELT IT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Chris: OH, [BLEEP]!
I KNOW.
THE INTERNET RESPONDED THE ONLY
WAY IT KNOWS HOW: WITH HILARIOUS
MEMES LIKE THIS ONE.
SEE --
'CAUSE YOU GOTTA HAVE AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE.
I NEED TO OPEN A SPACE BOTTLE.
SO, THEY ALSO HAD UNFOCUSED
OUTRAGE.
NOW, THE NORMALLY QUIET NATION
OF RACIST DOKLYVANIA IS FURIOUS
THAT THE TRAILER STARTS WITH A
SHOT OF A BLACK STORM TROOPER.
THEY INSIST THEIR RAGE IS LESS
ABOUT RACE AND MORE ABOUT
CONTINUITY, LIKE THIS FINE
FELLOW ON TWITTER:
STORMSTROOPERS ARE ALL CLONES OF
THE SAME PERSON (JANGO FETT).
NOT RACIST, JUST FOLLOW THE STAR
WARS LORES.
HASHTAG #BLACKSTORMTROOPER
HASHTAG #DOESNTMAKESENSE.
WELL, OKAY, TRAVIS GARDENER, AKA
TRAVGARD.
LET'S FOLLOW THE STAR WARS
LORE.
ALLOW ME TO READ FROM THE
OFFICIAL STAR WARS WIKI:
WOOKIPEDIA.
WHERE'S MY HYPE NERD, GET MY
HYPE NERD OUT HERE.
>> WHAT UP, WOOKIPEDIA!
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT. LISTEN UP.
CHECK IT OUT.
BY THE TIME THE GALACTIC CIVIL
WAR BEGAN, AN ERNEST JANGO FETT
CLONES WERE HEAVILY SUPPLANTED
BY CLONES BASED ON A VARIETY OF
TEMPLATES AROUND 9 BBY.
>> THAT'S BEFORE THE BATTLE OF
YEMEN.
>> Chris: FOLLOWED SHORTLY BY
ENLISTED YEVIN.
THUS, THE FETT CLONES WERE
INRONICALLY REDUCED TO MINORITY
STATUS!
>> MINORITY STATUS!
>> Chris: AFTER YEARS OF
VIRTUALLY FILLING THE STORM
TROOPER RANKS IN IT'S ENTIRETY.
>> TAKE A BREAK, CHRIS.
TAKE A BREAK.
>> Chris: IN SUMMATION, THE
FIRST STORMTROOPERS WERE CLONES
OF JANGO FETT, BUT BY THE TIME
EPISODE VII TAKES PLACE
STORMTROOPERS CLONES OF MANY
PEOPLE -- MANY PEOPLE AND MANY
ALIENS AS WELL AS NORMAL
GALACTIC CITIZENS OF ALL COLORS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> ALL COLORS!
[MIC DROP]
>> Chris: PERSONALLY I THINK
MORE RACIALLY DIVERSE STAR WARS
MOVIES ARE GREAT IDEAS.
SO COMEDIANS, WHAT WOULD A ALL
BLACK STAR WARS BE CALLED.
TOM PAPA, GO.
>> TYLER PERRY PRINCESS MADEA.
>> Chris: YES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DAVE HILL.
>> THE RIZA D2.
THANK YOU.
>>Chris: MORGAN MURPHY.
>> CLONES, THUGS AND HARMONY.
>> Chris: YES.
IT'S TIME TO START AT MIDNIGHT.